must win situation for
ding in game four against magnus who is
up by one point
is there chances for the chinese here
there's definitely chances for ding it's
early days it's level material but there
are some imbalances in the position and
it's mostly to do with the kings right
now look at why it's king yes it's
castled off to the queen side it's the
left side which normally signals
aggressive intentions but also it the
black king its counterpart sitting in
the center and uh magnus also low on the
time low on the clock he's just been
trying to work out which way to go with
the black king the black king is
definitely going i think the same side
as white's king it looks
i mean it looks too scary to go over to
the traditional side the king side
because white also on the h file has an
open line and here i think we'll see
ding pressure pawn there we go he's
trying to really hammer open this h file
there was actually a pin as well so
black's king had to evacuate before
anything opened up
and if we do see a trader pawns white
also has a better pawn structure
black has the two bishops in
compensation but black's bishop
especially the light square bishop just
staring at its own pawns right now
uh it's sufficiently imbalanced for dean
to be happy he can't have wished more
from the opening at this stage and uh
this one appeals to me more it does feel
a bit loose if black doesn't take this
pawn okay he does go for the simple
approach to the trade uh here i was
gonna say then black's pawns are still
weak and white has a pawn ready for the
end game here he's defending this pawn
and this looks fine for white but wow
ding really sneaky move there uh instead
of bringing his rook across which we saw
was easily uh kind of rebuffed the pawn
the thread against the pawn at least not
too scary he's found something even
deeper this pawn forward to block the
white queen's diagonal but this would
also leave weaknesses in the camp
yeah exactly sleep during the nights i
think it's a good practical try from
ding and he's at least forcing magnus to
spend a lot of time on the clock there
we go the night centralizing itself and
some quick moves i mentioned magnus was
itching to just slide his king across to
safety white's rook now clamping down on
this black sea pawn the black sea pawn
is a backward pawn this is the charity
cup we're doing our auction for i like
what magnus magnus has done so magnus
just stepping back with his queen the
queen really wasn't working on its
original square so why not
get ready to move it to somewhere where
it could potentially cause a bit of a
problem very complex i'm not sure who's
better for example after the white
knight moves to the side and okay i
liked your move the more i looked at it
another option was to just slide the
king into the corner just in case things
did open up ding meanwhile decides okay
the king may be needing some breathing
space he pushes this pawn forward but
okay that doesn't necessarily improve
things either the last one was hope
and
it was very sweet
and the queen does come out onto that
annoying square as we've highlighted and
okay and ding does go for my night
maneuver
but maybe not quite at the right minute
and wow
here comes the breakout
magnus has released the light square
bishop and pandora's box has been opened
yeah i think this was just impossible
you can't let the rook into the game so
uh ding first throws his pawn forward
before opening the box even further and
capturing this pawn he at least kicks
away the black queen and the black queen
i think is just going to retreat one
square yeah there she goes
safely
also on the same diagonal as the white
king so same dilemma exists if you take
this pawn black will play knight takes
pawn and uh yeah still some problems for
example you can take this knight hitting
the white queen and i think you're doing
well and we're heading in this direction
this position is on the board i think
magnus is going to at least save the
draw
which he needs to progress to the final
if he takes this pawn and okay maximum
pressure as we mentioned knight takes
here would be met by rook capturing
because the white queen cannot take back
due to this pin we would just see queen
trade everything disappearing from the
board
so therefore ding just defended his
knight in the center with his bishop but
uh some crazy tactics here
first thing that came to my mind was
whether black can capture this bishop
the evaluation bar shooting up in
black's favor maybe magnus can win this
game by sacrificing his queen and okay
magnus doesn't play it but this is a
very natural move as well bringing the
rook to the action yeah i think that
other line yes it might have been strong
but there were some complications black
could have ignored the queen sacrifice
and now look at all these trades
incoming everything's going to get
eliminated the queens have just left the
board and uh yeah right now magnus only
needing a draw he's a big favorite to
achieve it suddenly everything's got
traded and these bishops looking at each
other as well and just pawns pieces
disappearing things winning chances
disappearing with them all of you from
around the world coming together here
helping unicef in their help in ukraine
and can we make it to a hundred thousand
dollars today
when the show started chess community
coming together amazing yes
unfortunately for ding and all his fans
it looks like this is the end of the
journey magnus just being cynical
pushing pawns trading things off the
black bishop can now take a pawn uh ding
with his last move is actually
sacrificing in order to at least try and
create some imbalance in order to try
and win this game but unfortunately for
him he's currently a pawn down and now
white's knight capturing the black
h-pawn would just walk into a double
attack black's bishop would slide back
checking the white king hitting the
white knight that means white has to
lose a bit more time
and now for example the black king can
start making a move
it has to dash in towards the action you
know the king doesn't want to feel left
out
and uh knight takes porn but okay
why it's porn it's past born yes but it
can be caught very easily yes he can
bring his king over or he can bring his
bishop back and he realizes he is in
time to do this just in time with the
black king
but he's worked it all out and uh okay
here we go making his move and i was
tempting actually i thought was gonna
run to the left with the king
just to remind whites you know hey but
okay magnus doing what is necessary and
now there's a big threat on the board
the bishop is going to take a step back
and give a check to the white king and
that would pick up some material so
frustrating in these situations they
just tend to stop everything they can
easily just with one move flick back and
stop the opponent's pawns and
wow
blunder from
immediately
resigns ah with 44 five seconds left on
the clock there the bar jumps up
and it's over for dingley ran he is
knocked out of the charity cup world
champion magnus carlson reaches
another final in the mouthwater
champions chester